- Bed time is the safest,
coziest, warmest time of all.
- Hi I am Noel MacNeal,
I am a puppeteer, yes, it's a weird word.
This happened back in 1997
so I actually went in that morning
to audition for another character
for a game show that they
were trying to develop.
I got a call from Henson
saying please come back
'cause we want you to audition
for this other character.
I went in and I put on
what's called the helix,
it's like the understructure
with the hoop rings
and the netting and this
foam head and then I realized
wait a minute it is quarter
to five, this is a courtesy,
you're not gonna get this, so I just said
forget it you know what
I'm just gonna have fun.
Come Monday around six o'clock,
just shy of six o'clock,
that's when I got the call
saying Noel you got the part
and I was like what?
And it's like yep, so
that's how it happened.
When you're inside
you put your right arm up through
the neck and into the head
and you put your hand inside the mouth
so that the lower thumb is his
lower jaw and this is up here
and it was like a little trigger
for me to do his eyebrows.
Then my left hand was in his left arm
and there was a tiny little
string, a monofilament
that went up to a little ring in his neck
that came down the other side
to the right hand which was stuffed
so whenever I moved this hand
this one would move automatically
especially when he was dancing.
Give a guess, how hot was it inside?
I just put in a little
thermometer one time
so it got up to like about 92 degrees
but it's dry heat and the season,
especially the first season,
they would crank up the air
conditioning in the studio
so it would be freezing
and people would always complain about it
but it had to offset the fact
that the guy in the
bear suit might pass out
so they'd just crank up
the air conditioning.
- Hmm? It's you!
Ooh.
- Mitchell Kriegman who created the show
just had it so that Bear would
just like sniff the camera.
I came up with
him really jamming it in
and pulling it back out
which kids always reacted to
in fact one message I got
was from a mom of a kid
who was severely handicapped
and had not really responded
even by the age of two
and she was watching
the show and as soon as
Bear like jammed his nose
into the camera to sniff,
that's when she jumped back
and it was the first time
she had actually reacted
to the outside world
and they were thrilled
beyond measure so yeah,
sniffing can benefit the world.
I've been getting lots of
fan email from the parents
and from the kids of
autism and special needs
who've grown up with Bear
and how they said it's
still comforting for them
and I realized today
there's no show like that
where it's just sincere, it's just gentle,
and it's just as comforting as
Bear was, it's not too loud,
it's not in your face,
well except for when he sniffs the camera.
So then I've been trying
to develop my show
called the Show Me Show
for kids with autism and special needs
to kinda fill that niche
'cause I know for a fact that
the kid networks right now
aren't gonna do that, so.